and the idea of being a sexual human
being like a sexual person or an entity
is just
the hell are you thinking you know and
these some of these girls at church had
to live
two lives
at church they were this holier than
thou person but on the streets like
people hear this stuff right and so they
always had like this weird duality you
know and a lot of these girls too and
people always hear about this joke it's
like oh always get that catholic because
they were freaking the sheets but that
[ __ ] was true like because they had to
repress it throughout the whole thing
that you know
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast now normally we
don't really do this because you guys
are so used to seeing people that i i
know uh personally in the in the comedy
space but in the past
i've been doing this podcast now for
three years right and one of the the the
things that has been like an ongoing
theme is a talk about mental health one
of the biggest things why is because
it's something that i never really
focused on and you know i went through
counseling and everything like that when
i was younger but i didn't
i don't think when you kind of live in a
small bubble you kind of think that
everybody thinks the way that you do
especially when you don't have
conversations about stuff like mental
health
so
specifically when it comes to like i'm
just because obviously i'm korean
american
i only know about the korean american
experience right and we were talking
about it earlier i was telling you about
you know
people that i know in my personal life
who have parents that are in denial that
their kids need help simply because they
don't want to admit that something's
wrong
so like when i was a kid i remember
just
like even in like the church scale right
something like their kid i don't they
would have anger issues or something
else and instead of addressing what this
the issue that the kid has they get mad
at everybody else in the congregation
saying that my kid's fine you guys are
all [ __ ] up
you know and so this tends to be like a
big issue that i think that a lot of
like asian americans have
or maybe it's just like immigrant
parents i don't i i feel like a lot of
immigrant people outside of just from
asian people deal with this id this
denial that people need you know help in
terms of like the mental space like it's
just something that's never been
addressed and it's something that i had
to deal with when i was a kid because i
always assumed that i was okay
and one of the biggest things that i
started to realize was that um there's a
difference between like
venting and hanging out with your
friends and getting like professional
help from a therapist right because
those things are therapeutic but it's
not therapy and i didn't know the
difference and i'm like oh i could just
talk to my friends and i'm perfectly
fine and then every day nothing would
get solved we would just meet together
we would just gripe about the same
things over and over again and i would
still deal with the same issues and i'm
like oh i thought i had therapy and it's
not so um
liz is a is a therapist
and i thought it'd be great for you guys
to kind of hear the perspective of
somebody who's in this field rather than
somebody for me who's going through
therapy instead so um one of the topics
that i really wanted to talk about uh
you know and you wanted to bring up as
well
was kind of like
the the issue with
i guess like therapy and like asian
culture and how
i feel like or maybe we feel like a lot
of people don't get the help they need
specifically in asian culture and why
and like i wanted to know your thoughts
on that
yeah i mean it is
so highly stigmatized right um not only
in asian culture but i think i also grew
up thinking therapy is only for people
who gets locked up in asylum or
something like that so if you go to
therapy you're really crazy um so i
didn't go start going to therapy until i
was
30 something 30 30 years old or
something like that when i started
my school for to become a therapist
i only started because i knew i want to
become a therapist and i don't know what
therapy is let's go check it out okay i
wanted to help people i i like mental
health i like um
i mean like psychology but i didn't
really know what i'd be doing
thinking like okay when i go to therapy
like they're gonna just tell me i'm good
you know like i felt pretty confident
like i know myself
you know a little that i knew i found
out so many different things about
myself like wow i didn't know i was
living my life this way
so my perception obviously then changed
like oh okay it's just really about
exploring who you are you know what you
want to be and maybe yeah if you're
dealing with crisis you learn how to
deal with it
oh yeah even so i didn't know like
therapy could be just anybody and it
doesn't have to be crisis management um
but yeah i i think still my parents
don't i don't think they really know
what i do they know that i get paid from
like talking to people but i don't think
they really know it's like wow but
they're feeling yeah like i i tell them
sometimes like hey you should really go
to you know couples therapy like
whatever yeah you need that yeah
i mean there's like an older generation
where i think there's like a big
difference now where people are starting
to understand the idea of like you're
not minimizing how you feel um
i mean there's like a there's a balance
between it both i think sometimes it
swings hard this way and it swings hard
the other way too
but um
like the idea of feelings that i think
that this generation has and
our generation too it's we have a little
more time to think about how we feel you
know so for you know i believe like our
parents and my parents the i thought of
like feeling it's like i gotta survive
right you know those things get pushed
aside yeah
you don't have time to
really truly i guess explore how you
feel right you're just busy making the
end meet and
your kids are crying you're you know you
have to pay bills and whatever so i
think when you when you're able to stop
maybe that's when kind of like you start
feeling things and what do you do like
oh i have such little time i'm gonna go
hang out with my friends or just drink
and whatnot right and
that's how you feel better a little bit
but you don't really get to yeah any of
your real issues like i think like
because i never got to know my father
very well through him i actually had to
get to know my dad through my mom
because my dad is like
he's weird because he's a he was a
pastor so you know he tends to his flock
and he takes care of these people but
when it comes to his emotions he's very
good at telling what people what to do
but the other way around it doesn't work
so well right
so when we you know i think like every
pastor kids kind of goes through this
this issue of oh you're so good at
taking care of everybody else but what
about the people in your family and it
kind of develops this you know a little
bit of resentment
and
i had to talk to my mom to get to
understand my dad better in order for me
to empathize with him because he just
couldn't talk about how he grew up
i literally know nothing about how he
grew up except from what my mom tells me
because he's incapable it almost makes
me feel uncomfortable you know and i
don't know it's like like that
generation like talking about their
feelings just like impossible
i don't think it's a skill that's taught
or encouraged a little closer to you
yeah
um
push it closer yeah like that there you
go okay um
yeah i think we're just encouraged to be
more just stoic and
[Music]
like pretend that it doesn't nothing
bothers you um i think that's the virtue
rather than talking about actually how
you feel i think i do see the difference
when i get like a millennial clients
they are much more open um about
anything even their sexuality and what
not but yeah they can definitely talk
about their feelings a lot better
yeah yeah because they're they're taught
that it's okay to talk about feelings
right it's okay to open up it's okay to
have
you know different feelings and issues
and problems but i think back then
no one that it was just like pretending
right you um
preserving some kind of image they have
to um i guess portray to other people
like yeah like i'm doing well i'm
successful my family's great and my kids
are you know going to top school and
we're we're being amazing and we don't
talk about anything that doesn't match
that image that i'm trying to you know
that was the only thing like with with
my parents one of the hardest things for
them to understand like i think i was a
very difficult child too like i didn't
really fit the mold with like the
typical korean kid so like i i remember
this conversation with my parent my mom
and she goes oh and she used to say this
consistently but as i got older i just
got tired of hearing and she goes well
what about what are these other people
in the korean community going to think
and i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] about
them
i was like i could literally care less
what they think and i told her i was
like you know at the end of the day who
do you care about more you care about
your kid or do you care about these
people outside
you know and but it's so hard for them
to detach
that that feeling of people watching
them and then seeing every single move
because my mom
because she's also the wife she's a
harmony and so there's a lot of
pressures that come with that but then
my mom also grew up like
in the shigor like tolado area so she's
like she speaks very
country slang pumpkin you know and so
for her she had to balance out this
whole thing of like why can't i be
myself it's because my husband's a
pastor so i have to present myself so
she would work 80 hours a week at the
business but still on sunday she would
have to create meals for the church so
she would work literally seven days a
week all the time just to keep
appearances 24 7. and i think that
becomes ingrained in her for so long
even after they left the church she goes
what would these people think and i'm
like who who are these people we don't
even go to this church anymore but
that's what they think about you know
yeah it's sad that that comes first but
i i think that's maybe also the
difference between community-based
culture and then like you know very
individualistic like western culture
right they think about
i think i mean people think about
how things affect us or what am i
getting you know
maybe even how i feel better than like
how other people are going to feel like
the whole thing about like wearing masks
you know like in korea like there was
probably no question asked like wear a
mask wherever you want everyone else and
you
you just wear a mask you don't question
right
um but here
you have to think about okay like is it
good for me
is it good for them but what am i
putting in my body yeah it's
understandable but also at the same time
there isn't any as much as a
consideration of like how it affects
other people or how do i look or but
yeah i think in asian culture there's
definitely a lot more pressure to think
about
yeah how do i
present myself to others or how do i
affect how does my action affect other
other people do you feel that with like
with your older asian clients um
that that's a big reason why they don't
want to come to therapy because of how
it looks like to the public
yeah
yeah for sure i think
um
[Music]
i mean
i think part of it is that they
i mean they don't even know what therapy
is you know so they they don't think
that it will work
and then
i think
just in case um someone finds that right
then it's going to ruin their reputation
and especially at church you know i
think
pastors actually offer help right like
they do um some
counselings and stuff um but yeah no one
goes
as far as i know like you know because
they're afraid
it's gonna get out somehow right so even
then like with religion through religion
they don't yeah they're not really
getting help either
what are some of like the the bigger
maybe reoccurring themes or issues that
you see with a lot of like um like asian
americans or or like even older asian
people that come through and seek help
with you
i'll say shame
oh yeah yeah yeah because i think
that's kind of
um controlling method of like
shaming people in
especially asian culture um to
get people to do something or not do
something especially like let's say
um sex right um
[Music]
i was taught when i was in korea that
sex is bad um
if you have sex with multiple people
before you get married you're [ __ ]
um you don't want sex
women don't masturbate you know you're
just a bad person if you ever think
about sex right um so of course
i felt really ashamed every time i
thought about this and later i was so
repressed i didn't even think i needed
sex or i want sex um so i had to do
therapy
for that but um let's say
something simple as just
like um
being a good student right if you're not
a good student there's a lot of shame
that you bring upon your family whole
family not just you right
you're doing this to our family
if you i don't know get in trouble it's
all kind of like shame based so
i think that's what i deal with the most
people feeling not good enough
they don't get enough positive
reinforcement and positive affirmation
so the only thing they get they do get
is negative
um
reinforcement right so
yeah your identity like surrounds
shame shame that you've been
accumulating like all your life about
everything
yeah i i definitely probably felt that a
lot too you know the idea of like that's
the motivating factor is that you do
this so you don't make us look bad
versus you do this because it makes you
happy or i was watching this uh this
docu-series
and i mentioned this on the podcast
before on netflix where it was
um they were basically
the suicide rate in korea is extremely
high yeah i make a joke about this so
i'm like korea never loses we're number
one so like we're like number one in
suicide we beat japan
oh my god i was shocked right because
six seven years ago japan was the top
yeah but then japan's like number seven
or eight now oh my gosh and the korea is
number one
and so
like i'm trying to figure out what
what's going on over there right like
what is it specifically in in that
culture because i don't know i'm korean
american right so i i came here when i
was like two or three years old so i
really don't know what's going on in
korea when i speak about the korean
experience i speak about my korean
american experience in a town called
sacramento so it's very niche right
so you know one of the things that they
brought up was um they had a couple of
students they basically asked them like
oh what are your dreams they go i don't
have dreams i know what goals are
you know i figured out what my goals are
by the concept of a dream i don't know
what is it you know i don't know what
this is right so i wonder if that's like
you know made me think like what is the
emphasis of of
what did they emphasize what it is to
live in korea like
is it just simply to to knock off these
these pillars in your life like these
gold marks but when it comes to what you
personally want you always have to push
that aside in order for you to kind of
uphold this image or you know get this
amazing job but they never really think
about okay what makes me happy and i
think like you know korea too because of
how
you know after the war how fast we
rebounded the emphasis on education was
so important education is the key to
freedom and wealth and it's always been
like that and i think that's why to our
credit why korea bounced back so hard
after we were devastated after the war
which is like a sign of our resilience
this podcast is brought to you by quip
good health starts with good habits and
quip makes it easy by delivering all the
oral care essentials you need to care
for your dirty ass
mouth listen the quip electric
toothbrush is loved by over seven
million mouths that's seven million
mouths my friend more than your mom
time sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses to guide a dentist recommended 2
minute clean yes my friends reusable
handles in a range of sleek metal hues
including best selling all black and all
pink as well as bright plastic colors
sure to make a pop to your bathroom
counter my quip
electric toothbrush looks dope every
time somebody goes in my bathroom
they're like oh what's with that
toothbrush i'm like it's my quit baby
respect it looks better than your ugly
ass thing that you have on your
shank counter sorry don't mean a
disrespect but i love my quip now
straight up real quick if you guys don't
know with stylish and affordable
electric brushes starting at just 25
you won't be paying through the teeth
for better oral health i'm talking about
sexy and affordable what is that that's
a davidson guarantee
if you go to get quip dot com slash
genius right now you'll get your first
refill for free that's your first refill
at get quip dot com slash
spelled
g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com slash genius quip
the good habits company but then after
that when things are better what are you
left with and these kids are like oh
these these promise jobs that we have
we're not getting them because there
aren't enough jobs
so they're like well i studied my ass
off i went to all these cram schools and
now i'm here and i don't have a job what
am i worth you know
yeah i mean
i think
so it's been like about 20 years since
i've
lived in korea or or more
when i was living there i felt that
um i think when i visited too it's still
very materialistic and um really based
on achievement right so if you don't
have the right phone if you don't drive
the right car if you don't have the
right stroller you will be treated
differently you know i know here too in
la like if you go to like maybe west la
you know
people will look at you kind of like oh
what are you carrying what kind of car
you drive but it's like that everywhere
in korea um so
again you're ashamed right
if you can't afford the right phone so
you'll be bullied or you know what not
um so it's always i think about what
what you look like or what you appear to
be as or what you have what you achieved
rather than thinking about like what is
my like
dream or um
passion you know
goal in life you know do i have any
purpose in life i think it's just really
like you're saying um meeting those like
um milestones in in life like right um
going to
um getting into the college and then
after that oh i have to go get my
masters and then doctor or whatever but
in meantime i'm accumulating all these
wealth and that's what i have to show
for and that's how you're i guess valued
a lot of times i mean i'm not saying
that that's like
everything but i mean i definitely saw
that like
excuse me
like even when i went to um we stopped
off in um
i think incheon like the airport and i
was there like this
i saw everybody in the airport dressed
up i'm like where are you going it's
like going like you're going to be in
the plane for 12 hours what do you have
your makeup on you know but it's the the
i i didn't know and then mariel had
explained that to me and said oh you
don't walk outside looking like the way
you do i'm like really but i'm gonna be
in a plane
so
what is this and then we took business
class seats and i saw everybody they
were dressed up to the nines i'm like
you're gonna be on a plane for damn near
16 hours like be comfortable but it's
just
i was the outsider you know yeah
yeah i think that there's
there should be some balance between
like being respectful to others where
you're
i don't know present presenting yourself
in some ways that people think that
that's what they're doing but sometimes
yeah it's like overdressing and all that
i think my mom always tells me whenever
she sees me like why aren't you doing
your hair i did my hair today
like uh put some makeup on
and it's not for her it's because you
know she might have a guest or something
and you know and i'm gonna show up as
like whatever so she's she's afraid like
you know yeah that's that's interesting
because like i maybe it's because
i think my household my mom is so
she's a tomboy
so like the only thing that she probably
cared about was the my father's image in
the church and then she didn't want to
hear like the chanzorio so she's like
just just do it because i don't want to
hear this crap right because my mom
never really well at church she did you
know she wore her makeup or whatever but
she's like the the other mother has like
the fanny pack and the visor and the
vest so i think i never grew up with too
much well i'm also a boy so i i don't
know i know um mariel i mean she's
talked about on this podcast too where
her mom
like i've never because i don't have
girls in my family so i don't know what
it's like but it's
where's your hat how come you're not
wearing a hat you know how come your
makeup you should wear something a
little more girly yeah and even at the
age she's like 30 and she still hears it
it's like what what is this like what is
this thing that you have to feel like
you have to control your child even when
they're an adult like i would even
understand straight out of college or
whatever but she's in her 30s like what
is this like what is this idea that they
feel like they always have to do this
and in my mind i'm thinking that's
stressful on you like that you have to
constantly just helicopter parent over
your child like 24 7. but i i like i
didn't know this because all my cousins
are boys
i don't i don't see this a lot but then
when i saw it with her i was like oh
this is this is stressful
you know
never stops yeah my mom would tell me
like
well i don't know if i can say this i
don't think she's gonna watch this
she'll tell me oh you're getting fat or
you know your face is getting rounder
you know what are you doing
you should stop eating or something like
that and and it wasn't like malicious
way it was
in loving way
it's like as lovely as it can be yeah
but yeah it hurts right and so yeah i
think i
really became paranoid about like
gaining weight and um
looking certain way and all that stuff
do you feel like a lot of like um if you
have um
[Music]
a lot of asian
clients like they did the girls feel as
a lot of the issues about their personal
image
yeah for sure but i think um a lot of
times what i see more is
you have to be perfect in every way
like not only that you have to look like
a model and you know really pretty
whatever um skinny but
you also have to be like intellectual
you know you have to be top of the class
you have to be a lawyer or doctor or
whatever you have to have you have to be
the whole package yeah i mean
that that pressure is so i i also feel
like
a lot a lot of like uh kids have to deal
with that a lot you know it's like the
the idea
well i kept reading these memes like
maybe starting from like six or seven or
eight years ago it's it's the idea of
you can have it all right you can be the
the businesswoman you could be the
stay-at-home mom you could do it all at
one time but that's not fair it's also
very unrealistic like
i think the idea of it was empowerment
right
but it also made people feel inadequate
at the same time when they don't reach
these benchmarks but how fair is that
it's unfair how how can you do this like
i don't i don't i see my friends right
now they have kids right and
sometimes i see them they're trying to
do it all they they and i s they're worn
out they're worn the [ __ ] i just hung
out with my friends over the past
weekend and it's like she's like i'm
tired i'm like yeah i'm glad you said
that because it looks like you're so
well put together but i look at what she
does and i'm like i can't handle what
you do like i look at you and i start
stressing out
you know but it does wear out because
trying to be this idea of the strong
millennial woman
who has to have it all and if you're not
then you're not this you're you're
you're um you're backwards like you're
such an old-fashioned woman who doesn't
do all these things but
you know balance is everything like
there's a give and take in everything
that you do but nobody really like talks
about that it's always just the meme
right
yeah so you have to be perfect i think a
lot of asian americans especially um
women too
i think they're more like perfectionist
and that's what they struggle with the
most and now maybe their parents are not
living with them and so they don't get
that external you know uh pressure so
much but now it became their own voice
so now they're telling themselves like
oh you're so stupid you made that
mistake what happened to you oh you
can't even do that oh you're supposed to
juggling be juggling everything why
aren't you doing it you know so again
now you're shaming yourself
right so how do we get out of that you
know you're it's really a vicious cycle
you know um
[Music]
because you are bound to make mistakes
but if you don't allow it
um there's no compassion so
shame and judgment you have to deal with
that so there's a lot more i feel
um the stress that's
um
given to you like just from daily living
and on top of that what you're adding is
like
you know you're torturing yourself by
just going over all these mistakes all
the time or what you're not doing what
you're feeling um
and then yeah it just keeps accumulating
and one day a lot of times you know
you'll have a like a panic attack or
whatnot things start breaking yeah
that's when you realize okay something
has to change i see a lot of um
like i think people around my age or
i say four or five years older like
these traditional like korean dudes
they're so funny to me like when i look
at them and they they like to put on
this front that they don't they don't
care about anything like they don't have
like all these things don't affect me
but you know you could
see it like it bothers them so much and
like they put on this front a lot so i
always wonder too like i've one of my
one of my guy friends he's like one of
these like classic like i
when people talk about like toxic
masculinity like i don't even know what
that means sometimes but when i talk to
this guy i'm like that's what they're
talking about you know i'm like
you have toxic masculinity and you know
i know this dude because we grew up
together and he was like a hyung
but he talks just the way his dad does
and it's just this idea of like
it's even hard to put it in the words
sometimes like the way he talks about
things like like he makes jokes about
like how big his dick is or also you
know like these classic like
these cringy like guy moments you know
and
he's not like becoming this like
socially awkward like distant human
being because he doesn't know how to
interact with people normally outside of
him talking to like his boy boys that
only talk about quote unquote
traditional male boy things right um
like when a girl walks by they talk
about their tits and ask 24 7 you know
they're like damn you're 40 now it's
like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about guy
relaxing you know it's
when i see that i like i always wonder
too it's like what would happen if he
went to therapy like how much could he
unpack but like and you know you can't
really force somebody to go into therapy
you can tell them like hey you should
try it out like even me bringing it up
to him he's like i don't need that [ __ ]
like i'm happy i'm like you know that's
not what everybody around you thinks
though because you put off a very
different vibe from how you are so like
for you
have you ever have to deal with like
those type of like where they actually
kind of reached the point where they
came into you and then how do you unpack
that
um so i think it really depends some
people come in
at least
because of certain event they
have some kind of insight into their own
behavior so they'll say okay yeah you
know what all this time i have no idea
but this happened and now i feel like
there's something there i want to
explore
sometimes they just come in thinking
like okay there's nothing more i can do
i i just need something so i'm here but
i don't even know what therapy is i
don't know if it's gonna work and i
don't even know you know if you're good
any good whatever um so they just give
it a try but i think
in those instances i think um
they're not really open
to
like feedback or suggestions or you know
even really exploring their own thought
patterns or uh behavior
because they know
they they know everything you know i i'm
good like i'm gonna just keep living my
life this way but i just don't know why
i have this issue
you see i always wonder like how do you
deal with that because i know somebody
now who's um
i kind of got him to go to therapy but i
he's a very tricky case right because
i've known since we were kids so
like he's been going therapy now for
like three or four months right but it's
progressively getting worse and this is
what i was curious about so how do you
deal with somebody who's very good at
saying the right answers
right because
he's very good at that so i feel like
for him when he goes into these therapy
sessions like
he always tries to therapy somebody
who's therapist again you know so he's
he's thinking about what is the answer
that i can say that'll make this person
think that i'm becoming better versus
him actually trying to explore being
better
and i've seen him do it multiple times
and i always i was very concerned like
okay he he wants to try therapy he's
going to give it a go and just the
things that he's saying and i'm like
you're doing it again like you're doing
that thing where they're like
listening to what the therapist is
saying and then
he goes
what's an answer that they want to hear
that makes me feel like i'm smart you
know like how do you deal with that
because that's i feel like that's like a
lose-lose situation how do you unlock
this pattern because that's you know
because i could hear it sometimes
because like we'll be in the house and
he's he has his like online thing is
echoing i hear it and i'm like he's
doing that [ __ ] again like i know him
you know yeah and so i'm like how would
you deal with that
i don't think i had a case like that but
um something similar would be when i
used to work with um eating disorder
population um there were
um
adolescence and
just talking about the whole
perfectionist thing they're very
perfectionistic and number one
you know student in the class and what
not people pleaser so they will approach
the therapy exact same way you know
they're like teacher's pet right so they
want to please a therapist like oh i did
like all these homework the coping
skills that you gave me like i did all
this you know so when you ask like oh
how are you feeling i'm good i'm good
okay so like
we talked to your dietitian and you know
we talked about this blah blah blah
oh well no i'm still doing good yeah so
they um just tell you exactly what your
friend is doing like what you want to
hear because they
want to please you they want to be this
good
patient or a client yeah right so then
you have to challenge them a little bit
right gently like hey like i feel like
you're just telling me what i want to
hear or hey are you really doing good
because i i heard that you cried the
other day or i heard you know blah blah
blah something happened
um then you know slowly i think if you
create that space for them like you're
safe you can talk about your um maybe
struggles here because i think most
people i don't know for
my clients who are dealing with that
issue they didn't have the safety
of talking about your um your issues you
know um
so you just
feel like you have to you know um
yeah i guess perform
you know yeah so when you let them know
i think hey
you don't really have to do that you
know you're accepted no matter what and
i'm here for you
i think they can slowly start changing
you know this podcast is brought to you
by ship station you guys know i've
talked about ship station and the
holidays are coming up and if you're
selling anything online it's time to
prepare for the busiest time of the year
if you're not using ship station you are
going to be stressed the [ __ ] out i'm
telling you managing inventory and
juggling orders you've got a lot going
on this holiday season makes shipping
the easiest part of your day with
ship station i
freaking love it it makes anything easy
i hate shipping things especially when
it comes to just like merch or products
and if you've got something that can
automate it for me let me tell you
something it's easy to import orders
from any sales channel on this thing you
can automate just about any shipping
test spend less time sorting through
orders and more time doing what you do
best which is getting that great product
out to your lovely lovely friends family
or customers my friends you have to get
on this it's never too early to start
prepping for the holiday rush so get a
head start with ship station my
listeners can use my offer code
geniusbrain and get a 60 day free trial
just in time for the holidays that's two
months of stress-free holiday shipping
for free just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter in geniusbrain shipstation make
ship happen
um but it it really depends on i think
people's like insight level as well
willingness to change but also insight
level even if you point something out
sometimes people just don't get it yeah
yeah
and some people are more
open and so they they get it right away
and
yeah they put everything into practice
and start changing yeah cause like it's
always hard to i mean just in general
just talk to somebody who
feels like they know everything there's
just no room for just oh i can learn
something from this conversation it is
so frustrating yeah you know what i mean
they never last those types yeah they
come in knowing everything i'm like why
are you here like
yeah
but um yeah i had
clients like that for sure they'll do
one session or two session they don't
come back because they already know
they're only coming to hear what they
want to hear and i'm not going to give
it to them then
like okay yeah you're no good yeah i
just know what i'm doing already yeah i
mean that's so frustrating too it's like
so there's there's a point too even for
you with clientele it's like oh i
that there's
like you can't help them it's like
it's just like you're you're kind of
like doing your own thing at this point
yeah
it's sad you know and i think we do try
as therapists different ways to approach
that like when they when you think
when you can tell that the other person
has this
guard up because they think they know
everything but if you can get to
where does that come from then i think
we can really get somewhere with it like
um why do you feel like you have to
present yourself that way that you know
everything right
is it insecurity or it doesn't stem from
your childhood right
does your parents make you feel
inadequate so you present yourself that
so if we can get there i think we can
you know do some work but if they're not
willing to look at anything so like you
know if i see that then i'll start
asking questions so that we can get to
those things um but if they push me away
then yeah i can't i can't really do
anything about that that's like the
remember when i first went to therapy
and then
the i think the hardest part was
getting into that comfortable space
where you can
say things without feeling like you're
going to be judged it's like something
you you always think in your head but
you've never told somebody else right
because you you might have told some a
version of it that wasn't 100 truthful
right but when you say it out loud it
almost feels like for me anyways it
feels like there's somebody else talking
and i'm watching some
somebody else say these words
you know and it's so odd like one of the
things that i could never say was um
you hurt my feelings
i could never say that specifically to
that girl out there i couldn't say it i
would say it in a different way yeah i
mean you're being annoyed
you know like why are you acting like
this but really it's just you hurt my
feelings you know and i couldn't say
these words it made me feel
weak it made me feel very vulnerable and
i didn't like that
it bothered me so much even to this day
when i say you hurt my feelings i could
feel my like it feels like my teeth are
about to fall out right
because you're admitting you have that
much power
to hurt me right so it is a vulnerable
place to say something like that yeah
i'm giving you that power willing me
right to hurt me or please me or what
not right so it's hard to admit that
that is rough like it's one of the
hardest things that i learned how to do
because
nothing else that i would say
would effectively communicate how she
would make me feel
so it's like if i told her you're
annoying me that's just gonna piss her
off you know if i just tell her hey what
you're saying hurt my feelings she goes
oh
i'm hurting his feelings you know i just
have to be okay with her just not having
that knowledge you know and it's just
it's so disarming you know and that this
army thing where you don't feel like you
have no shields you have no weapons
makes you feel super weird like i just
hate that feeling at all because i don't
think i would ever tell my guy friends
that like he says something that annoys
me i'll be like hey bro you were my
feelings
i don't think i had that but i feel i
felt like okay well
this is a woman that you're going to be
married to you should be able to say
this out loud and
just that step was just like my palms
are sweating right now just thinking
about it like even when i like i said to
her like like a month or so ago and even
then i was like oh just
she hurt my feelings
but you know it took that one statement
and she understood and then she
apologized before it would be so
roundabout yeah
why are you oh knowing you
yeah yeah and it would just cause a
fight when really it could have just
been one simple solution of oh i
understand what emotion you're going
through and i think like that disarming
part especially for a lot of like
like korean males it just it doesn't
really happen it's just easier to call
somebody stupid
you know and obnoxious rather than
saying like what you said affected me
this way right well it's easier to just
blame the other person and saying like
oh well you always do this you hurt um
you
um act crazy or you're just
inconsiderate or whatnot versus like i'm
hurting here
you know i feel so sad i feel so alone
when you do this
so it's easy to hide behind anger and
just
some kind of um
criticism or an attack
rather than you
excuse me being really vulnerable with
the other person and saying hey it makes
me feel this way and i i'm actually
really hurting here i need your help or
i need i need some affirmation here i
need your support
it's hard
you you kind of touched upon like the
kind of like sexuality and like young
like asian american like females when i
was at you know when you bring that up i
always think about like
church was such a weird thing
like the experience of the korean
american church was so odd because of
like you mentioned the whole shame
factor right and the idea of being a
sexual human being like a sexual person
or an entity is just
the hell are you thinking you know and
these some of these girls at church had
to live
two lives
at church they were this holier than
thou person but on the streets like
people hear this stuff right and so they
always had like this weird duality you
know and a lot of these girls too and
people always hear about this joke it's
like oh always get that catholic because
they're freaking the sheets but that
[ __ ] was true like because they had to
repress it throughout the whole thing
that you know i told this one funny
story where i knew a church leader who
she
would have sex right and i remember we
were hanging out and this is after i got
older right and then she
she she didn't leave the church but she
was graduated from the youth ministry
and she was like yo people are talking
openly we're having jokes or whatever
what not and they're like oh yeah like
oh she doesn't have a virginity you're
not a virgin she goes i'm still a virgin
i was like you're not i know who you
hooked up with all the time like your
boyfriend she's like you guys hooked up
all the time she goes no he didn't come
inside me so i'm still a virgin oh my
god and i'm like what what are you
talking about right now where does this
logic come from is this from the bible
like
where did you get this you know but
there's this weird battle that they have
to deal with all the time and excuse
their perception of like number one
being comfortable with their selves
their body or something but a lot of the
girls that i dated that went to a church
they had to deal with that and i had to
deal with it because i didn't know how
to be around them and as a young boy i'm
not comfortable with my sexuality so i
you know it was just really hard to
navigate you know yeah and i have not
only asian clients but um i guess
they're if they're really religious
they
go i guess figure out a way to go around
it so
just like what you're saying they do
oral sex manual sex whatever everything
else but they just don't do genital
effects right and they're like oh yeah
we're a virgin
that's hilarious to me yeah it's crazy
but
yeah that's how they well because you
have to i guess reconcile with the idea
of being a good person right um from the
religious values and
you know things that you want with your
boyfriend or girlfriend right
so how to like make it okay so i think
you talked in one of those um episodes
uh rationalizing right yeah um so yeah
when there is um cognitive dissonance
like that i think we just find a way to
make it fit
yeah right like there was this thing
where we saw somebody put this on a tick
tock but i didn't know about this but
there's like this mormon thing called
soaking
where they literally the guy takes his
penis he inserts into the vagina and he
just lays there as long as he's not
thrusting it's not sex
but this is a real thing
so i texted one of my friends who grew
up mormon he didn't really practice i
was like i just texted him one word i
said soaking he goes
he writes lol he goes how do you know
about this
i was like this is real this is some
real stuff he goes dude i used to soak
all the time because i felt like i was
gonna go to hell so i would just stick
it in and we would just cuddle
it's like a real thing
it's the funniest thing ever but it's
just like
it's it's
yeah that whole church experience about
like kind of how they made you feel
about your body and like obviously like
sex before marriage and if you don't
believe in sex before marriage is fine
too like
you know whatever floats your boat you
know but i think like the idea that
sex makes you into a bad person kind of
[ __ ] up a lot of my friends right and
and there's guilt right you feel guilty
all the time while you're having sex or
if when you're thinking about sex
oh
you're living in hell right really
yeah um
but yeah i going back to like what we
were talking about earlier i had a lot
of
asian clients who had family members who
like committed suicide um
and
they sometimes they knew they they saw
the signs sometimes they didn't see it
at all and i think people just kind of
miss out on everything um
i think people don't even know what
depression look like right um what does
the depression look like oh like when
they're telling you like i want to kill
myself yeah that's depression no it can
look very different right it can look
like just they're in bad mood for days
and days and days
and not really have a real crisis right
um
but yeah
after like years of that maybe
that will get there to the point like
i'm going to kill myself but um
i think people don't know even if what
they see is like serious
what do we do with that
oh we're not going to put him in like
you know hospital so
just let him let him stay home and like
maybe with time he'll get better
yeah that's how things happen because
you know no one's informed like what
mental health is and what you do where
the resources
yeah yeah it's so hard to approach like
i think like
you know what we mentioned before with
um like i i've known somebody who've
their family has
they're just in complete denial you know
everybody else sees it but then because
they it's like the
like adhd like you tell somebody like
their kid has adhd they go like it's not
dumb
nobody told that your kid's dumb
but there's a different way to deal with
your kid because
he's hyperactive or he can't he can't
focus
um
and dealing with that especially like
for me when i was a youth minister and
you know sometimes with these kids
and you know they would ask like the
kids would act up or whatever and i'm
like hey there's something off you know
not mentally with them personally per se
but like
something happened in school or
something like no there's nothing wrong
with my kid that's immediately first
thing they say off the jump right and
they completely they get mad at me and
i'm like listen i'm trying to help your
kid out like i'm with him more than you
are you know i have conversations with
these kids and they tell me stuff that
they don't tell their parents but the
moment you bring it up to them it's like
hey
maybe we should help your kid well with
this situation because like for example
there was a kid who was hooked on um
oxycontin
um
this this kid was just
stealing stuff from his family members
um
just to pay to get some pills because
pills are expensive the high doesn't
last very long super quick
and i brought it up to them i was like
hey so for this kid robbed his cousin
and took all of his games places or
whatever stole that stuff
sold it just for some pills i knew about
this
so i talked to them and i'm like hey he
has
a problem he's a drug ad he's a he's a
drug addict and he's he goes he's fine
it's the first thing they said to me and
i'm like
what do you mean he's fine like he's not
fine like he's he's like no like
there's stuff that you don't know about
like he you know his friends got him to
do it like i'm like
what do we do here
you know like how do i how do i get this
this family to understand like hey your
kid needs help and that's like
even something small like that even when
all the evidence is laid out before them
they take it and they sweep it under the
rug and i've had to deal with that
multiple times whether it was them their
kids having anger issues whether it was
kids like i'm not sure if these kids
were depressed but they would just be
you know i don't know what happened in
their day but you would ask their
parents about it and say and they would
just be like you're wrong
right and they would ignore it and you
see these kids get progressively worse
and worse and worse and
so yeah you're ashamed but also i think
you have to deal with the guilt of like
is it something i did right but if you
admit it at that point now you have to
take responsibility right and you're not
ready to do that you're not going to
therapy
right so you just push it away no it's
not here i don't see it
yeah that personal responsibility the
property thing is like what messes them
up the most right it might be like the
inner thing of like if i
if you if i recognize that this thing is
wrong with my kid i played ahead of that
as his parents right and it makes them
feel bad right and then they have like
all kinds of unresolved you know
personal trauma or whatever are ready so
they can't add another thing on the top
you know
on top of it right because they're
they're not doing anything with it right
so it's just being accumulated
um but yeah like i think you make a
really good point about addiction
people find ways to deal with whatever
they're dealing with if you're not in
therapy um
so addiction is one of the ways to cope
right num num whatever you're feeling
i don't want to be here because when i'm
here really here and now it's so painful
so i have to go away i disappear i have
to check out
so
whatever the addiction is it's a way of
checking out right was that whether
that's drug addiction um
gambling game sex addiction
so you learn to just cope by numbing
yourself and you don't feel anything
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals you know my friends
i have been sponsored by betterhelp
because i love them and the fact that
other people have used them by listening
to this podcast makes me so freaking
happy because you are focusing on your
mental health and if you're wondering
how easy the communication is you can
communicate in under 48 hours and no
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional therapy
done securely on line listen if you are
not comfortable
meeting people face to face do it
through better help it's a great way to
get you started better hope is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change therapists if needed if the first
one you start doesn't match up with you
and by the way it's affordable than
traditional actually more affordable
than traditional online therapy because
my friends there is financial aid
available for you so visit
betterhelp.com genius that's better help
h-e-l-p and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional a special offer
for genius brain listeners get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
genius i feel like that's what a lot of
people just have to deal with the like
the moment you recognize it the the work
that comes after scares them
because
i feel like as a therapist like
you know when i when i spoke to their
when my first therapist they unlocked
something i was scared to go further
because i'm like what else do you want
to find out about me then i don't want
to deal with it
it's like oh you you uncovered something
and then now i have to deal with this
and they go okay let's go deeper i'm
like hold on a second i can't you know
i'm just dealing with this right now and
it's scary it's frightening you know
yeah and that's why like having an
insight and making a change a real
change is completely different thing
it can be scary or also you know it's
because it's a lot of work you know it
takes time and whatnot but
um even if you have the insight of okay
yeah this is how i've been living my
life and that's not what i want
i'm gonna do things differently
it's just hard to do you know hard to
take on like okay so then what what do i
need to do oh well i realized that i got
a job right
after college as a lawyer because that's
what my mom wanted
i hate it
yeah what am i going to do quit
and what i have to start all over again
i'm not ready to do that so i can't make
that change
yeah right or if you realize you
mirrored someone that who you weren't in
love with and you know you're not happy
are you gonna leave
no i can't leave no one in my family got
divorced
no i can't bring that to my family that
kind of shame you don't
i mean for you because you never
uh like therapy
wasn't like an option on the table when
you were younger what made you want to
go be a be a therapist
yeah i think i just always liked
psychology and
i took kind of weird path
career-wise but i went to art school and
i did worked in design car design
industry for a while and i knew
actually it took me 10 years to realize
that i was unhappy so unhappy so
depressed that i needed a change
so i just kind of started exploring and
i found that there is something called
art therapy oh my god what is that you
know that sounds kind of cool cause i
have our art background and then i found
a program lmu loyola
they offered marriage and family therapy
program and art therapy clinical art
therapy too so i thought oh yeah you
know what i always like psychology let
me take some courses and see if i still
like it and i did
so
i just started the school but um i think
it i always had that in me um
wanting to figure things out i was
always fascinated by people i always had
people come talk to me so i think a lot
of therapists already play that role
before they become a therapist in their
community they were already a counselor
whether that's in your family or your
in your friends group or whatever so i
think i was already doing that too so i
was pretty
you know familiar with it like talking
about feelings you know and
telling people like yeah you're going to
be okay you know does it ever like
personally like wear you out because i
always wonder for therapists like how
you guys deal with it because
um
[Music]
i it stresses me the [ __ ] out like i got
to a point where i think
specifically during pandemic a lot of
people
you know and every now and then i tend
to be the vice person i'm very
careful with the things that i say
because i don't want to say things that
i'm more i'm more like a listen than i
give advice right and just like oh like
is that how you feel and then just have
them talk it out because i feel most
people kind of have the general tools if
they're fairly intelligent and
emotionally intelligent they can kind of
figure it out for themselves but after a
while like it started wearing me out and
i'm like i don't want to talk to none of
y'all anymore
because i started losing my mind you
know because i i started i don't know
what it is like maybe i'm absorbing
their crap and it's like making me feel
a certain way and i got to a point where
even marion i was like i don't hear
about anybody's stuff like everybody
just leave me alone like i'm gonna just
go on these long walks and i'm gonna
assess how i feel because i can't
because you know i call these people too
like i call them like theme
they use me as their like emotional
tampon like i absorb everything you know
and i had to figure out too were certain
people who
it's this idea of friendship right where
i'm like oh i'm not sure if we're
exactly friends because i think you just
used me to
dump all your emotions and then you [ __ ]
up my life and then you walk away you
know right and i'm like oh i don't think
this is a friendship like it's not very
resourceful
yeah i'm like
you're using me as like this cheap
therapist it's like and i have no tools
to help you out so i just walk away
wrecked yeah you know and they come back
with the same issues over and over just
to dump it on me so like for you as a
therapist like how do you cope with like
your emotions then
so
um
i think most of us a lot of us go to our
own therapy um i've been in it for
several years too um and we have
consultations group consultations where
we can talk about specific top topic or
just processing group two we can do that
i do talk to my therapist friends that's
like free therapy
i do that too
but i think over the years you kind of
learn your limit and you have to
set your own boundaries around it so for
instance like when i was working with
kids i
really suffered because the kids you
know get abused at home so like they're
okay they're great like well they're
with you um and parents are like
fix my child right and but they're
actually being abused at home so
you know that after therapy they have to
go home right
and you know what's what happens at home
so it just breaks your heart you know so
i did realize this is not something i
can't handle every day because i take it
home
yeah you know um so i knew that i i
couldn't work with um
kids
and there are other things too um
also like severe trauma you know i i
tend to absorb a lot more so i don't do
that i'm mainly
attachment therapist so i do a lot of
couples and individual relationship work
i do some trauma as well but not in
depth because i know that i'll be
too affected so
that's what i do kind of try to
know my limit and you know set my own
boundaries but also
i know that
other therapists too
you have to learn how to
not
i guess um yeah absorb everything
you know um
we learn like we we there's a phrase
like leave everything
like at um
at the office right yeah and so whatever
you heard or what not you don't bring it
sometimes people literally like
leave their notes or whatever it is at
work so they don't really take it home
yeah yeah because i feel like as a
therapist you have to be pretty
empathetic and when you're like an
empath having to carry that weight with
you all the time is is so hard
like it's like i can't like the moment i
got into a serious relationship like all
my friends were close like
female friends like they would you know
they they're a lot more
emotional they could talk about the
problems
i was like hey guys
i only got enough space for this girl
now like she's already a handful so i i
don't i don't like it's not that i cared
less it's just i couldn't handle it you
know right
yeah there there are um sessions or
clients who
make us feel like wow like you've been
through so much and i feel kind of
trained after because there were so many
like abuse history or whatever but there
are
um a lot of other sessions other clients
maybe even though that's what they went
through when they're able to make change
or whatnot you feel really rejuvenated
and happy um i think it's both sometimes
yeah it does happen to us but just
because we're listening to people like
suffering or complaining or whatnot that
that doesn't always mean like we're
going to feel bad sometimes because
we're able to help them we feel good um
so you get a little bit of both every
now and then yeah that makes sense
yeah i i didn't get much of that but
like i got a lot of like oh yeah this is
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] exhausting right
for me especially like because i work
with couples more when i know that they
came in like
thinking okay this is the last resort
yeah we're gonna split after this if if
this doesn't work right and then
when i know that they stayed because of
therapy because they made so many
progress so much progress then yeah it
makes me feel really good right that i
help someone and that i'm doing
something meaningful in my life
i think one of the cool things too that
therapy does is like allowing somebody
to kind of uh
kind of look at themselves right because
it's you know we talked about how easy
it is to to blame somebody else and i
think like for a majority of my life
that's what i was doing it's like oh i'm
angry because this person did this to me
right but when you when i took a step
back it's like oh i kind of grew up in a
very violent household
you know so generally everything makes
me angry like the first way that we
would solve our problems is to break
things in the house punch things fight
scream like even when i was a kid like i
used to grow up um
i remember when this kid um stole my
[ __ ] i forgot what it was it was like so
when you go to like these um
flea markets you get these like glitter
sticks and this kid stole it from me i
came back home and my dad was like
where's the [ __ ] that i got you and i'm
like oh the kid stole it he goes cool
well
closes the door he goes you'll be able
to come back home when you get it back
and he goes
okay i had to go back again to fight
with this kid like we got into a fist
fight i grabbed my [ __ ] came back and
then he was like cool come back and have
some dinner
you know so our ways of solutions you
know i'll be for my dad too he just
didn't want me to get bullied you know
and there was a two thing there was a
good thing that happened with that it's
like after that i never got bullied but
at the same time
i just learned to solve things by
violence you know it's like oh if i want
to get my way around i'm going to beat
the [ __ ] out of people just so they
respect me and it caused this thing of
like oh when i'm angry i can break
things i can smash things i can you know
punch holes in walls and whatever and
this is how you get rid of your anger
and like the idea of thinking about why
you're angry wasn't something that i
ever did nor did i want to do i didn't
have the tools you know so it's like i
think like i see that a lot so i saw
this i'll show you after this podcast
but i have a friend
okay i don't know if it is ptsd or it's
comforting at the same time it's weird
so she showed me this clip
she had a shiktang and she's like he's
eating but he just stands up and out of
nowhere starts screaming at his friend
like in the middle of the restaurant
just like he just stands he goes
like this is who i am you know and he's
like telling him to step outside let's
go fight or whatever and i'm like why
does this
70 year old man
you know think that this is appropriate
at a restaurant to take like the shot
glass smash it in the middle of the
restaurant chuck these beer bottles and
he's just sitting here thinking that
it's acceptable
you know and i looked at that i'm like
why is this and it's a little too
familiar like i look at it i'm like oh
that's just
a korean guy i'm like wait no that's not
okay you know that's not okay but when i
look at it i'm like oh it's just a
korean guy being a korean guy but you
know those behaviors aren't acceptable
but because i grew up around it i i'm
like rationalizing it as like he's
korean it's fine right you know
and that's actually quite um common
i think in in men in general
men are not encouraged to talk about
feelings
cry
men can cry boys don't cry right so only
emotion that's acceptable is anger
right you can't be vulnerable right
because you can't be weak
you can't tell anyone that you're sad
you can't tell anyone you're depressed
you can't tell anyone that you feel
lonely
only thing you can do is being angry
right so that's what you do
underneath that anger there could be so
many different deeper emotions but only
thing that people see is anger so people
say oh yeah that person have anger issue
well maybe they're really depressed or
maybe they have certain issues that they
haven't been able to deal with right
so
i think
it's it's really difficult for men to
come to terms with that like
later well this is how i am i nothing
bothers me
okay so we have to really sit down and
explore okay like when you feel angry
what are you thinking
oh yeah i'm thinking like this person's
you know not respecting me
what does that mean
you know that means like
i'm not worthy
oh do you think about that a lot
yeah yeah
where does that come from like oh yeah
my my mom said like i was worthless all
the time or whatever right but that
takes time they're not going to let
their guard down like like that right
you have to build the rapport and we
have to talk about a lot of things and
before but anyway i think it's a lot
harder for men to get there because
you're not supposed to you're being
[ __ ] if you talk about your yeah your
feelings right
whereas women we have freedom to
talk about how mad or how sad how
whatever we are um
it's just accepted
so it's it's a little bit easier for
women when i looked at that video i was
like i wonder what have happened if you
just would have said you hurt my
feelings
like wonder if you would have just said
that but there's absolutely no way that
she was gonna say that yeah the first
thing he did was take a little shot
glass smash it on the floor tell him
let's go take this outside let's go
right now
i'm just like what happened here you
know what
like i'm surprised he's not dead already
from like a heart attack just like you
could see that rage you know and it's
funny too
the funniest part of that video too was
when there's a younger korean guy that
walked up to him and he's telling him to
leave he could see me the big korean guy
he walks up to me looks at me goes i'm
so sorry
i was like oh now that's not a female
waitress there's a bigger guy coming
around suddenly you calm down but it's
like that macho thing yeah yeah you know
it's just it's just so sad to see right
and then people think that oh well i was
just really overwhelmed with the anger
or
you know that person said this and so
it's justified it's never justified
right your action is your own action no
one made you do anything right you can
take many different choices but you made
that choice of being angry and smashing
that shot glass you could have said oh
you hurt my feelings or you could have
just walked away right so
i think that's the thing like they have
to also come to terms with that okay
no one's making me actually do anything
no one's causing me to be angry
they are doing the things or these
things are happening but i'm still
in control over my how i experience
things i can get mad where i don't have
to get mad
that's so hard yep that that is probably
the hardest thing to do because
especially like you're in the heat of
the moment your emotions are flaring
it's like this person made me do this
like what other choices did i have
exactly
exactly yeah it's really hard to do but
i think what helps me and some of my
other clients is i always remind them
like
my goal of life is not suffer to not
suffer right so to reduce suffering
what am i going to do in that moment
i'm not only reducing everyone else's
suffering right that's like a byproduct
but how do i not suffer here
me getting my blood pressure really high
anxious angry whatever it is you know
it's not worth it why
something bad already happened to me
and i add more suffering on top of it
just because i'm reacting to it in a
negative way right um thinking oh it
shouldn't have happened you know this
person a jerk
all of that just
adds more suffering onto me
that's the idea of drinking poisoning
praying for somebody else to die yeah
exactly yeah so am i gonna like so you
have a choice at in that moment if
you're able to stop which is really hard
to do too if you're able to stop and you
can think about okay so should i do this
should i do that someone just yelled at
me should i yell at them back and suffer
another 15-30 minutes arguing with them
or just walk away and address it maybe
later when they're calm yeah
i we were also talking about um
what i didn't know about this work you
know i went to this whole deep dive just
reading all the stuff that you sent me
about people with bpd borderline
personality disorder and i started
getting anxious
reading the stuff you know just because
of
like i haven't met
too many people like that but just one
person in particular right where they
kind of like checked all the boxes and
it helped me understand why i couldn't
effectively communicate with this person
ever you know and
literally only one person i've ever met
like that in my whole life and you know
when we were talking about it
it was like
how the [ __ ] does it how would a
therapist help a person like this it's i
i don't even know where to begin like
somebody who has
zero sense of personal responsibility
like zero not even any like everything
that happens in their life is is because
of that and it's never this way there's
never a mirror in front of their face
how do you help somebody like that how
well
if i think what you're saying applies to
other personality disorders too like
narcissism yeah um that's just personal
disorder but um
for bpd or borderline personality
disorder we have a specialized treatment
for it just because it's so hard to
treat because they do lack insight and
they have really high um
what do you call
they get activated very easily right so
there's something called dbt dialectical
behavior therapy and
uh
someone just designed that program to
help
the borderlines right people with
borderline personality disorder
and so what you do is you do individual
therapy like a few maybe twice or
something like that a week and then you
have group
and you can call your therapist and
check in it's really intense it's an
intense program and
i think once you
start that i think there's hope and
people
i've seen people change but to get there
is really difficult like you're saying
if you never think that anything is your
fault you're not going to seek therapy
so
unfortunately they don't end up in
therapy much so
it's like other people around them end
up being in therapy because they're
suffering because this person is causing
habit right in their lives
and they don't get help a lot of times
it's it's it's like
i can't remember all of it now because i
remember i just read it all like
throughout the night i just like binged
it like i was reading all these things
if so definitely what is borderline
personality disorder and what are the
the markers for it
um
so
the main thing about borderline personal
disorder is
they are
sensitive to rejection any type of like
perceived rejection
so
you're just talking and you told them
like oh yeah you know what like that
skirt that you're wearing like yeah that
was like okay but like not not the best
you've been you were so far or something
like this very you know not benign
comment they can get really upset and go
off on you right there
right because they have experienced
severe rejection before in their life so
it's mainly um from their caregivers
maybe they didn't feel loved or didn't
have a good relationship or maybe
their parents left and you know they had
to i don't know raised by a single
parent or something like that whatever
it was if they felt severe pain from
rejection
um that that's
how they are hypersensitive to any type
of criticism so even if it's not a
criticism they can take it that way and
then go off yeah so there is
hypersensitivity um and then also you'll
see that um
i got i'm forgetting the words like the
anger outburst right um
pretty common
um
another thing is they have poor
boundaries so
they might be one of those people like
who you just met like oh my god david
like i love you like you're so cool
let's be best friends and then they come
over they like start calling you and
they text you all the time or whatever
um
just instant right um
with yeah i guess like with a therapist
and
um client relationship too they do that
too
to us you're the most amazing therapist
i've ever met you know and they start
emailing you all the time like i have
this this happen
we can't do that we can do therapy via
email they keep doing it so they push
your boundaries that's another thing
right so
you don't feel quite comfortable but
because they're pushing it all the time
you feel like okay like okay maybe you
can come over or maybe just just one
this one email like okay right
but
if you do one thing wrong in their mind
wrong right let's say i replied that
email a little bit i don't know three
hours later than one hour later
i'm the worst therapist ever you know
the worst human being ever
and all kinds of you know
i don't know accusation language you
know you can possibly imagine and then
the next day like oh i'm sorry that i
did that
and everything's forgotten
those type of things like
scare the hell out of me it's like i've
never been able to put into words maybe
the reason why i don't deal with this a
lot is because
i've never
i i call people who [ __ ] on the first
date i don't like people who [ __ ] on the
first date like when i meet you and you
tell me everything about you it always
put me in any since i was younger i
hated it i hate it so much yeah it's
like
who the [ __ ] are you right i'll know you
like that you shouldn't be telling me
this stuff you know and
i think that's probably one of the
bigger reasons why i've been able to
avoid it for so long is because that was
one of the first tell signs of like i
don't trust you because there's
absolutely no way you should be giving
me this type of sensitive information
when we let met five minutes ago yeah
this is something odd and i've always
avoided it until you know recently like
this person who kind of became into my
circle was through other people and
there was one person who was managing
the the issues that they were having and
then when that person made that one
mistake
villain
you know
trying to tear this person down i'm like
who is this but i didn't know who this
person was and so after that this person
tried to latch themselves into different
parts of the group and then when it came
to me i was like this is weird you know
i don't know who this is and the reason
why it was because i never had to deal
with it because that person who was that
person's hero when they were just
unloading all this stuff onto they were
managing it for x amount of years
forever how long
and when it all came crashing down they
had to latch on to somebody else so lo
and behold went to every single person
and now none of us talk to this person
anymore that we all just like oh this is
crazy and i had no idea i was like what
is like i've never dealt with somebody
like this before and i couldn't figure
out why because i've always been very
good about
that
specific character trait i hate it right
yeah i think it's just because maybe
where i grew up it's like you you or how
we grow up is like you don't ever let
people know the stuff about you like
that you have to be very chill like i
grew up in a very nice area so the
things that people know about you is
only stuff that you let them know right
and then you're really close close
friends you tell them
everything because you trust them with
your life but this person would
i would know about their
past trauma their relationships like
stuff that happened to them as a child
and like in a two-hour conversation i'm
like
what is this like why why do i know this
stuff about you and then lo and behold
you all started unravel yeah it's it's
really sad but you can
probably see that that's a pattern for
them and they don't have any
long-lasting relationships because they
can't keep any because something like
that happens something someone who
disappoints them then they cut them out
or they you know they
get super angry um
whatever it is you know or they start
yeah bashing
crashing you or what you did or whatever
um very vengeful can be uh yeah the the
the vengeful thing was the thing that
shocks me the most it's like like you
should what is wrong with you like i
don't even know how to like i've just
never met people like this yeah so the
the idea that
like my thing was like
why do you think about me so much you
know like
like every action that i make
is
is this person plotting against me right
what are they like they're always the
victim yeah so like i got scared i was
like should i just not
i had to literally cut this person out
completely like you can't see any of my
social media or anything because i can
do like a post about me having i don't
know seafood and then it'll be like oh
you know i hate seafood so that's why
you posted that seafood picture right
it's like what is this
so
you know
that's why even
therapists like you have to be
specialized in it to deal with something
like that you know but as a therapist
you know we're trained to have
compassion and you know try to
understand where all that is coming from
right and we know that
no one who like experience severe pain
is gonna turn out like that you know so
we know that they've been suffering and
they're still suffering a lot right
um um god i can't remember the name
names of the person uh lanagan um she is
who developed the dbt that uh the
treatment and she compares
borderline personality disorders um
people with brain personal disorders as
like a burn victim so
your skin is still raw it's not like
stressed or anything you know and that's
how you walk around every single day
that's how
sensitive hypersensitive you are and so
you're always watching up for like some
kind of clue some kind of sign that
people are planning against you or
they're hurting you or they're doing
something to you so you know you can
imagine how
painful that life is you know it's it's
so sad that they have to go through that
every single day but because they lack
insight because they don't get help a
lot of times that's kind of like a you
know life pattern you know they um get
really close to new people
you know and then they're okay for a
little while and then when once that one
per new person makes a mistake they're
gone like no i can't deal with you they
keep repeating so they don't have any
long-term truth
that's like um
i don't know a lot of people didn't like
this years ago like i used to say in the
podcast is like i rarely develop
long-term bonds with somebody who
doesn't have any friends
and it's a big sign for me it's like
there's a reason it can't be everybody's
an [ __ ] there's no way like there's
absolutely no way everybody is an
[ __ ] and what i found out you know
younger where my dad used to tell me
this too but you know when you're
rebellious as a kid anything he says is
just whatever you know he's like people
don't have friends like you have to look
at who this person is i'm like dude dad
you're supposed to be a pastor what
happened to this loving man but he was
just giving me these warning signs and i
had to find out the hard way it's like
oh there's a reason why they don't have
any friends you know there's a reason
why these people just they come in and
out of people's lives 24 7. they can't
create long and strong bonds like for
example with this person after you know
we all just up and left because of what
this person was doing
the next thing you know i hear through
the grapevine throughout some of our
other friends who are still friends with
this person that
oh like they started hanging out with um
like their siblings and mind you because
i know everything about them they
would say terrible stuff about them you
know haven't talked to them in years and
they reconnect and it's like telling me
like in their like instagram feed posts
it's like here with my day ones for life
it's like you didn't you haven't talked
to them in like
years you know but it's almost like it
almost felt like they were trying to
show us like
i'm still good right you know and i'm
like i don't even follow you anymore i
didn't hear it through somebody else
because they they didn't they didn't
know what was going on and they're like
this person's acting a little weird like
this person started hanging out with
their mom again and the mom was terrible
to her uh you know and it was just like
what what do we do here at this point
and so i'm like okay and i in the back
of my mind too i'm thinking like i want
to mend this french because we grew up
together so it's like i want to mend
this friendship
but i think i'm just only holding on to
it because of time because of the amount
of time i put into this person rather
than looking at who this person is i'm
looking at friendship as a as an
investment factor like oh i invested so
much time with this person maybe i
should hang out with them a little more
but it's like it doesn't matter like how
does this person make me feel you know
what is this relationship like and i
think as we get older i started really
my threshold for [ __ ] is so much
smaller like it's it's it's so curt i'm
surprised like how short it is you know
and i think
probably
you've learned to prioritize your
happiness and your mental health and all
that first before like thinking about
okay yeah like let me be just
understanding and you know like they're
good people like to keep making mistakes
i need to you know i need to help them
well
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
um but where can they find you if they
wanted to um you know
seek your counsel um i have on web i
have a website called couples healing
center or you can email me to
lesbittherapy.com i mean at gmail i'm
sorry i'm like
sorry at gmail okay email yeah and i've
i've personally sent a few of my friends
over to liz and they've loved it you
know and i think like one of the cool
things is like therapy is i call therapy
like churches like you've got to find
the one that that's right for you
it's not a
one-size-fits-all type of thing and you
know a lot of the people that i've been
sending over to you are like korean
people because they just don't believe
in therapy
and i think there's a lot of cultural
nuance that
every time they had to go to a therapist
that wasn't korean
80 of their therapy was them trying to
explain to them why it's like the way it
is right yeah which is a factor so much
time and it sometimes people just don't
understand so why did your parents throw
the rice cooker it's like move on past
this like this is
you know so
you know it just makes that's how it is
yeah i don't know i don't know why i'm
gonna explain this to you i don't know
why korean people just start punching
holes in walls you know so
yeah you could check out liz if you guys
feel like you um
connected with her in some type of way i
hope you guys enjoy this podcast genius
brings every thursdays and sundays and
up until next year next year is only
once a week because it's wearing me out
so
but we'll see you all next time peace